so how are you guys now today good good
great hanging in there
hanging hanging so with a movie like
this where it's sort of a very
heightened reality you know it doesn't
really stick too close to what reality
is like is that kind of loosen up the
performance a little bit does that make
it easier you're gonna say yeah it
definitely does I mean my character was
raised by feral cats and it's and it's a
totally realistic and mature I love
someone that's why it is yeah
yeah but it gives you a lot of freedom
to get weird so is there one thing one
gag or one throwaway line one joke that
that didn't make it in that that comes
to mind that you were like really wish
that wasn't I do I do remember that I
ate I was eating fish and chips out of a
newspaper and I was eating the newspaper
and I don't think that that is aware and
I ate so much fake newspaper I don't
think that I was kind of I think there's
a ton actually there's a ton there's a
ton of stuff that will probably on DVD
extras yeah yeah which would be like you
mentioned you don't get to speak for a
large portion of this film about your
performance still very very funny I'm
wondering what the key is to you know
just doing a comedic performance without
without work yeah it was a it was a fun
challenge for me to have to kind of get
super physical the fun thing about the
character is that you know if if the
information you have is that she's
raised by feral cats there's really
nothing I can do that is too weird and
my direction from from a time the entire
time was basically to go bigger so I
feel like I found myself just getting
completely out of my head and making
absurd choices that it was it was a lot
of fun to watch let me tell you so to
celebrate Holmes and Watson I'd like to
do a lightning round of riddles
to start off what can travel around the
world while staying in a corner that is
dancing yeah that's true yeah you're in
a corner I have a lot going on in here I
can just stay on the corner and I'm
somewhere else
what has hands but cannot clap Lawrence
what gets wetter and wetter the more it
dries Oh ocean I don't know what's what
gets wetter and wetter the more it dries
yes I have no clue the answer is a towel
let's towels dry you drives me you
trying something else I didn't write the
river oh I just the last one I have is
I'm tall when I'm young and short when
I'm old
what am I the day interesting the answer
to riddles is always like time the
answer is a candle well now I want to
know the other ones that's the corner
one was a stamp ok travel yes and not
having hands Oh having hands is a clock
oh I cannot clap
[Music]
you